so grandma you know Jeff and I have been  dating a few years now we thought it was  finally time gram-gram hello  it won't let me send you a video I mean  I guess I could go with a different  woman but this one's perfect all right I  guess I'll go with the smaller one I  need can we make a new rule let's  download all of our music so that we can  save our data for the map app as long as  the same rule applies for social media  for the first two hours of a road trip  sounds great let me pick another time to  bicker when we're in no danger of being  eaten okay all right great oh he got  cute since high school  yup okay what was his name look it up  see oh okay he saw me and I think he's  coming over here okay I'm out of data we  haven't seen you in ages  it's Mike we took AP chem together yes  we did we did it was great